Président je vous en fait monsieur le
Président mais monsieur et les ministres
vous sentez que nous sommes dans une
colère froide voilà les événements sont
passés
je regrette ce qui nous arrive
collectivement mes chers collègues je
pense que la droite c'est la toriale est
en train de rentrer dans une machine
infernale qui est en train de la
submerger y compris en termes d'image il
comprend un terme d'image ce qu'a dit
notre collègue et les Nass assis sur
l'irrostabilité les amendements qui
n'ont même pas été examinés
ils n'ont pas pu être examinés
techniquement mes chers amis c'est
impossible et ils ont été déclarés
irrecevable
peut-être que vous considériez que nous
n'aurions pas de riposte potentiel après
l'utilisation de
l'amendement prioritaire porté par le
rapporteur
mais nous avons le droit de nous
exprimer essayer de défendre nos idées
vous ne me voulez pas manifestement et
il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'imperfections pour ne pas dire
de bricolage dans la gestion de notre
débat de ce soir je le regrette monsieur
le Président vous n'êtes sûrement pour
rien mais le constat il est là et les
membres de mon groupe donc ont décidé de
s'associer à la démarche qui est la
nôtre de vous laisser vous voterez
peut-être l'article 7 cette nuit et bien
nous en rendre compte devant les
Français qui ont défilé aujourd'hui mes
chers collègues nous vous laissons entre
vous